Barbara Vishnevsky I can't imagine life
without coal she's lived in this house
near Warsaw for nearly 40 years and in
winter when temperatures plunge her
coal-fired boiler is what heats the
family home my hands would be cleaner if
I didn't have to use coal to heat my
house but electric heating would be so
much more expensive I couldn't afford it
on my salary more and more poles are
aware of the problems burning coal
entails after all the country has more
than 30 of the European Union's 50 most
polluted cities according to the World
Health Organization but it's also
addicted to coal-fired power plants like
this last month for EU agreed a target
of net zero emissions by 2050 but with
an opt-out for Poland the e used just
transition fund aims to generate a
hundred and eleven billion dollars over
seven years to help coal dependent
nations and regions move to a green
economy Poland which relies on coal for
80% of its electricity is a clear
candidate and things are going in the
wrong direction here in 2017 Poland's
total greenhouse gas emissions went up
around 4 percent on the year before
Greenpeace activists say Poland should
be doing so much more and they've staged
eye-catching protests like this one
against coal imports in Gdansk while
some political parties now talk about
phasing out coal by a certain date
previously a taboo the government's
building more coal-fired power plants
the majority of the new countries
already either ditch call or have a very
specific call phase-out plans if our if
Polish government is not serious about
this thing you know no government should
receive funding if they're still
building coal-fired power plants this is
simply irresponsible it seems clear
Poland will have to change course
dramatically and quickly some believe
it's heavy reliance on one energy source
could make it easier to take the right
decisions because Poland for many years
invested only in coal and steel we have
very old cold five coal-fired power
plants
paradoxically we may make make now this
leapfrog like invest in the modern
technologies so we need to invest in the
new power system so why not in
renewables climate change is already one
of the main worries for the Polish
public moving away from coal use will be
expensive that the EU funding plan aims
to make it as painless as possible
nadine barber al jazeera warsaw